Speaker 1: OK, let's talk to a few more people.
We're taking calls via The David Pakman Show
discord, which you can find at David Pakman
dot com slash discord.
Make sure to become a subscriber to the discord.
It's free.
I'm selling you nothing other than a good
time.
Let's talk to why don't we talk to Maria from
Ohio.
Maria, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hello, hello, hi, I have one comment
and one question generally.
My comment is I just really want to say I
appreciate lately I've been noticing you're
you're making an effort not to stigmatize
mental illness, unlike the caller yesterday.
And I've noticed I mean, just just, you know,
things that you how you treat the the general,
I think urges people to just ridicule people
who are of the other side, who are clearly
mentally ill or maybe not clearly, but suspected.
And I just I really appreciate that you're
making an effort to to not further stigmatize
mental illness.
My pleasure.
Brad, thank you.
And then my question is just, do you have
any tips for talking with the older generation
about fixing this policing issue?
Because I have a hard time talking with my
parents about it.
They're they're in their 70s.
And they just their general assumption is
like to assume that they need the military
militarized gear and everything and need all
of this stuff that clear.
It's clearly not proper to fund that way.
You know,
Speaker 1: Will, I think I would probe and
say, why do you think police departments should
be militarized?
And they'll have some answer and then say,
OK, can you give me some examples of situations
where police being more militarized helped?
There really aren't many.
I mean, you know, make them just sort of examine
how they came to these conclusions because
what where what what type of plot were what
part of the world do they live in Ohio?
Maria.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Yeah, we're from Ohio.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, in wherever they live in Ohio.
Are there examples of when police being more
militarized help to resolve a situation that
they can think of?
And if there aren't any examples they can
think of, then say, OK, well, what about in
the entire state of Ohio or what about in
the entire region?
Tell me exactly how we've been.
We've benefited from police being more militarized.
And then if you can get them to realize it
actually hasn't really done much for anybody,
then you could go to the next step of look
at the money that's being spent there aside.
There's also a fiscal issue which may may
appeal to them in some way.
I don't know.
Speaker 2: Hmm.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I try and talk a little bit about it.
Like you should kind of be upset that your
tax dollars are being used this way.
Right.
There are much better places for them to use.
You know,
Speaker 1: there's debate over whether we
on the left should use right wing framings
to talk to people who are on the right.
Some people say you should.
Some people say you shouldn't.
But it seems that the fiscal thing is at least
worth trying.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah.
Oh, all right,
Speaker 1: Maria, thank you, Maria from Ohio.
Great to hear from you